KANG THE CONQUEROR
Scott Lang.
This place isn't what you think.
PEYTON REED
One of the most fun things about
Quantumania is we are taking our
characters into this entire universe.
The Quantum Realm.
KEVIN FEIGE
Under the guidance of Peyton Reed,
Ant-Man's becoming one of our most beloved
characters and beloved franchises.
He loves these characters and like us he
knows we can do something totally unique.
PAUL RUDD
Peyton Reed,
he has a really strong vision.
MICHELLE PFEIFFER
He's able to weave in and out of action...
...the humor, and the heart.
PEYTON REED
This is my third Ant-Man movie.
And because of that, we were determined
to make the third one essential and
a real trilogy capper.
JONATHAN MAJORS
The epic nature of the film...
...you want to experience
on the big screen.
PAUL RUDD
It's so transportive
and visually striking.
EVANGELINE LILLY
This movie, it's a sweeping universe.
PEYTON REED
The sheer size and scope of it was
tailor made for IMAX and 3D.
EVANGELINE LILLY
I feel like you can't get a big
enough screen for
Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania.